your brothers and sisters in the slum
net from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah will
give you even
yeah so just start by telling me your
name and what you do just
okay so my name is Muhammad hijab I'm
the co-founder of the sapiens Institute
and so what we do is
um we have adult education courses where
we explore theophilosophical issues
particular and religious issues and so
um really my work has been around that
you've been described as a YouTube
influencer okay yeah
what do you who do you influence
I actually done a poll on on my
Community page some time I'm going to
see what kind of audience and to be
honest this majority of Muslim
population
um when I looked at my demographics I
saw that there was a significant number
of women
females that are actually listening to
me as well I would say the majority of
men maybe about 60 to 70 percent and the
age group would be about 18 to 35 years
old although other categories that are
closest to it are like close second
places so it's mainly um religious
YouTube videos that you do
I mean I think a lot yeah I would say a
lot of it is a lot of the output is
religious but a lot of it because my my
PhD is in the philosophy of religion is
philosophical so like I would deal with
issues to do with like the philosophy of
religion uh proving the existence of God
or political philosophy like exploring
feminism and liberalism these kind of
things I've published works on these all
these books on these issues about five
so far
and so um
yeah I think there's there's two aspects
of fundamentally fundamentally what I do
there's a publishing aspect and then
there is the kind of teaching aspect
um these are the two main things I mean
obviously I've been an activist for many
years as well you know so on issues to
do it's okay
So when you say the activism what kind
of issues so Palestinian rights okay
uyghur rights
um I think the far right act is like
against the far right okay and I would
even add to that other extremist
ideologies like even Islamic extremism
I've got a whole Channel dedicated to
Islamic extremism which my family knows
because I speak about all the time
called SP files which I deal with all
kinds of extremism on there and um
that's not even violent extremism but
things which I believe is a slippery
slope to violate the violent extremism
uh in addition obviously to Violent
extremism with an Islamic circles as
well so I think that my activism
actually stretches to that obviously
recently the in Indian minority Muslim
issue in India as well I think these are
the main issues that I've been dealing
with
okay so you you see your role as trying
to prevent young Muslim men getting
drawn into its reasons
a big part of my role is that yeah
um to be honest with you I would say a
big part of my Lord is apologetic in
nature meaning that
um I try and articulate the faith of
Islam the people who want to know about
it
um why because I feel like there's a
major disconnect between what the
religion of Islam actually says and what
people actually perceive it says
and people don't realize how pragmatic
the religion of Islam can be even from a
traditional standpoint so we find
competing narratives in the west of how
Islam for example should conform
with Western values this kind of
hegemonic
superimposition I would call it right
you should be like us be in our image I
find that almost a pseudo-colonial
narrative and I'm opposed to that kind
of narrative I feel like we have enough
within our own infrastructure to be able
to be as pragmatically Puritan if you
like as we want to be so that's one
thing and at the same time I would say
that
I will people don't even know the
fundamentals of Islam like the basics
and stuff like that I feel like there's
a major one of the big big parts of my
role is an educative function
so um just to teach people about the
basics of Islam we don't feel it's
incompatible with the West
well it depends on how you define Islam
and how you define the West right so if
we're defining Islam
as a set of propositions which says
there's only one God worthy of worship
and that uh you know we want communal
Harmony for example with people with all
face and stuff like that which is how I
would Define it and I would say living
in the west and being tolerant with
Western people that's absolutely fine
and it is compatible if what we mean by
the worst is in fact these set of
um hierarchically derived ideological
standpoints which Islam must be
subjected to for example social
liberalism or secular feminism then I
would say actually it's not compatible
with those things in entirety although
there's a there are areas of
intersection so it depends on how we're
defining the two Notions but if we do
Define them in the way that in the way
I've suggested in the first instance I
think is there is compatibility there of
course
so if we turn to Leicester now how did
you first hear about what was going on
in Leicester
I will actually privy to it through kind
of looking at Twitter because I'm on
Twitter sometimes and I saw very angered
to be honest with you to see this kind
of hindut fart ideology the far-right
ideology has been exported from the
subcontinent
and make its way into
my country England and to see people
being vulnerable people being attacked
um it was like for example the 22nd of
May there was a there was something I
saw with 30 people attacking one
individual and it was all on camera and
I was shocked uh by that and I was very
saddened by that so when I started
looking at these kinds of things I left
and thought the police would take care
of it unfortunately the police didn't
take care of anyone after weeks
why did you decide to go down that
particular weekend when there was the
disorder for two reasons fundamentally
one of them is to actually
kind of ease tensions and de-escalate
the situation I wanted to let people
know young people that I knew I had an
influence on not to break the law and
this is very clear on the public record
but I said this don't vandalize things
don't break the law but at the same time
to be honest with you I wanted people to
know that they could lawfully use
reasonable Force because why should the
Muslim Community or any other community
have to deal with this radical ideology
which has been exported from the
subcontinent which is a fascistic racist
ideology which talks of the which talks
of Hindu supremacism right why should we
have to deal with that and there not be
a response which is lawful and befitting
I think as a moral duty I think I felt a
sense of moral obligation that I thought
let my people know of this what they
could do reasonably I don't do this for
any Community not just the Muslim
Community honestly I would do this for
anybody that I saw was in trouble or
that Injustice was being done to them
well you're not from Leicester and you
went down and that could be seen as
quite provocative you know did you go
down there to cause trouble why didn't
you keep one away from me you could have
just done a YouTube broadcast you could
have said to your people via social
media these are your rights don't get
involved you know don't have any
violence why actually go to Leicester I
did all those things I mean on Twitter I
was engaging with with the issue in the
ways that you've just suggested but I
just feel like there is an ad added
benefit into actually Hands-On
interaction being in the thick of it and
to be honest with you although like a
lot I've been born ready in London as
you know uh not from Leicester but
having said that I don't distinguish
between people who are in less than
Birmingham on your ass in the United
Kingdom I think that if Injustice has
been done to any community in any part
of the United Kingdom or indeed any part
of the world that I can actually
influence but I should engage in trying
to uh stop that Injustice and so once
again this hindut ideology which was
very clearly is very clearly fascistic
in nature racist in nature requires
head-on confrontation in all legal ways
possible would you distinguish between
Hindustan and ordinary Hindus in
Leicester who were living their lives
and who were also appalled at the
violence absolutely and I think it's a
shame that there has been this
misrepresentation of the media where
such conflation has actually been put
forward and suggested because if you
look at this only one minute of the
second video
um that I actually clearly mentioned the
only thing I actually mentioned was
hindutva it was a message that didn't
find that don't ever do this again and
these kind of things and this particular
message had no mention of the word Hindu
at all in fact the titling of the video
had no mention the word Hindu at all so
the conflation has been made is not mine
it's actually a conflation unfortunately
which has been uh put forward by right
winged parts of the media and
individuals who have a meta narrative
that they wish to present which that
Muslim people are fundamentally or
inherently incapable of Tolerance and
that if Muslims engage in protest that
process is in fact an affront to Civil
Society or civil living a protest is
actually offensive
and so I think that this is something
which is intended to malign my my
character on the Muslim Community child
life
I need your code
would you do you want to do that
question because there was someone I
think it was all right but you can't do
it yeah that's right 26 26. actually
well with pause I'm going to change the
angle slightly so I might try and do it
this one is too short for sure thank you
my friend
okay Josh okay but do you distinguish
between hindutva and ordinary Hindus who
live in Leicester and were appalled at
the violence absolutely do and I think
that this intentional conflation between
the two is something which unfortunately
has been done to malign me as an
individual and my community at Large
clearly in for example all my
Publications one I speak in the terms I
do about the fascistic ideology that is
hindutva
which is uh you know it's in the network
of kind of Indian nationalistic
ideologies like the RSS as you know and
so on
it's clear that I'm talking about a
political ideology I'm not talking about
a religion or a group of people
um and I think that such confliction
that has been made is appalling and
unfortunately has framed me in a very uh
favorable one favorable way but you were
seeing you were caught on camera you
were talking about Reincarnation of
people coming back as cockroaches you
must have known that that would be
offensive to Hindus well to be honest I
wasn't actually mocking reincarnation in
that situation I was saying that if I
believed in reincarnation well it
sounded like you were it could have and
if so you know to the Hindu community at
large I have to offer my apologies to
the inter Community if it sounded like I
was lucky but I will say to you uh
clearly that in fact I did preface my
sentence with a conditioner if I
believed in reincarnation which I don't
think is logically absurd from a
theological perspective actually I think
if God wanted to know the real powerful
God if you wanted to reincarnate me into
a grasshopper or whatever they say
cockroach but whatever it is I don't
think that's logically impossible I
think that's possible uh I'm in heaven
hell I mean this eschatological Notions
I don't think
um of neither here nor there for me it
is the case although
uh not all Hindus are hindusta most in
the are Hindus so I was offering them
something which they can relate with
which relates to the eschatological
Notions and from that perspective I was
being hyperbolic in my speech wasn't an
attempt to mock Hinduism as a religion
and using that kind of inflammatory
you know those inflammatory worms and
stuff can you see how you were
you could be seen as inflaming the
situation rather than calming it to be
honest with you once again I feel like
this situation required confrontation
I'll be honest with you because
in all legal ways possible we're talking
about a new form of extremism here which
is new in Britain uh relatively new we
haven't seen this kind of tensions
before in the decades are part of unless
it is I haven't seen this kind of thing
yourself have you so what I'm saying is
that the reason why it requires
confrontation is because just like as
Muslims we are required to confront
extremist elements within our own
Community I think it's fair that Hindus
who have extreme servers within their
own communities like the Hindustan for
example and fascistic elements for
example the second Chief of the RSS
actually produced The Holocaust and
we're talking about something which is
and and recommended a holocaust against
Sikhs and Muslims this is we're talking
about a gold Walker we're talking about
a seriously extremist ideology here that
thing needs confronting and I feel like
me as a citizen exercising my freedom of
expression and speech confronting this
ideology in ways which are not legal
they're illegal is something which I'm
afforded and we should continue to do
but do you accept that the way you went
about it you know coming down preaching
on the street you know people listening
to you yeah of course they would have
listened to you they would have looked
up to you you should have gone about it
in a different way and try to calm
tensions
perhaps I mean once again I'm not saying
everything I do is I'm I'm an angel
walking on Earth and we all learn from
our experiences I mean I think this why
would you go down again if it happened
again I would go down again but in a way
that would be maybe less provocative I
have learned from the lessons of before
uh I would say things which are more
categorical such that I can't be quote
mined in the way that I was crop mined I
could not be maligned and lied about by
the ministry media in the way that I was
and I do think there's an issue here
having said that and taking
accountability for taking stock of my
own action I think it's fair for us to
say also that there is a different
reaction from the Press when a Muslim
decides to show or Express themselves in
political ways than there is from other
people and that is I think something
worthy of Investigation so you think
you've been branded an extremist
um
rather than somebody who preaches a a
conservative
ideology or conservative view of his
religion I don't know if any UK paper
has called me to be completely honest
and extremist they haven't gone that far
yet but it's on the public records
whether we're talking about Hindus or
Jews or Christians or any other people
community that I've only preached
coexistence the fact that a Muslim
person can be branded as an Insider of
hate or instigator-in-chief they called
me in fact I own this uh I'm starting up
a new brand now called instigator in
Chief t-shirts I'm going to sell them
get some money from the situation to
compensate me for the troubles I found
but what I'm saying is you know having
said this you know what I'm saying to
you is I've realized how poorly
represented Muslims are in the Press
and I feel genuinely yes that this is to
to withhold or to uphold I should say a
meta Narrative of the impossible subject
which is the Muslim person that requires
to be kicked out of the land or
something like that and so what do I
expect except for this I mean we haven't
seen much better than this I mean the
impossible Muslim subject who is uh you
know
intolerant and capable of anything else
but I've said the opposite I'm saying it
today on camera these are explicit words
I say that we want nothing but peace and
coexistence and harmony with all
communities will you accept that your
actions that day
you won't conducive to peace you were
you know Riley people up well I know
what you're saying to me but what I'm
saying is every action has an equal and
opposite reaction sometimes it's not
equal sometimes it's not opposite but I
didn't start anything in Leicester what
happened was on the 22nd of May 30
people uh rushed they beat up one person
and this was on social media and then we
saw more and more of these kinds of
events taking place and this was because
they were inspired by hindut for
ideology this ideology is a fascistic
racist supremacist ideology and what I'm
saying is that we like I'm saying to you
yes you're saying do you accept this and
that and whatever and I'm saying yes
except you can see we're comfortable of
course I need you guys to accept as well
that this ideology needs to be
confronted and we can't just and I
commend channel four I commend you in
fact for your reports that you brought
out where you're one of the only people
in mainstream media who even mentioned
the RSS who even mentioned hindutva I
want to see more of this kind of thing
because if young Muslim men
uh they feel alienated to the point
where they can't even be heard or that
their side of the story is not even told
I think that is a pathway to extremism
unfortunately which we need to make sure
uh is not facilitated there is an
argument some people locally feel that
this was a local issue local tensions
they could have dealt with it that's
what they're trying to do but people
like you coming from the outside just
made it all blow up 100 times worse
there is an argument for that but
there's there's no such principle
play I mean we're talking about uh we're
in London so people from Birmingham
shouldn't come and interfere in our
situation I don't know what from whence
such principle was was extrapolated and
to be honest if such principle can be
shown to be robust from the
philosophical perspective I may think
about it but this idea that people from
London shouldn't interfere in the action
of behaviors or the situations of people
in the lesson I think this is almost
like a village type we're living in a
village type mentality we're living in a
globalized world if I want to comment on
things happening in Africa there'll be a
lot of local nuances be aware of you
know you wouldn't necessarily know where
the Hindu areas are or the Muslim areas
or the interaction between the two fair
enough uh I accept all of that that's
why I have people that will guide me
into these areas where I can get a Sat
Nav I mean this is something which can
be mitigated I think what I'm saying is
that the reason why I went there is
because of my social media influence you
see I have social media influence I
don't think anyone less as a Muslim or
an activist Muslim has so I was and I
was able to actually bring forward a
narrative that very few in the media was
able to bring hundreds of thousands
almost millions of people watch that
narrative because of me so the way to
eliminate people like me from going to
Leicester is if the police can do their
job and the media can do their job if
both of those organs do their job
properly then people like me won't need
to travel at all and what happened to
you locally there's a there's one video
where a local Muslim boy is saying to
you you know you're just inflaming the
situation going home yeah
there were local Muslims opposed to you
being there I don't know if they were
opposed what it was is that I was
speaking for some time maybe 10 minutes
and I shouldn't have spoken to these
angry people for 10 minutes because I'm
a lecturistic so I speak for a long time
so it's like we've had enough we've had
you know we've had enough of this we
want to get involved with some protest
actually did you make the language I
don't know
they made me angry I mean once again
this is always reciprocal we're talking
about some young Lads in Leicester I
would say they're not really newsworthy
from the adverbs unremarkable situation
uh what I would say is that the
overwhelming majority opinion was that
people actually wanted me to be there
they showed me a lot of support as you
can see from the videos I mean people
are all around me thousands of them and
walking behind me and so in fact I was
made famous because people were walking
behind me in the in the thousands so if
we're talking about this or you've got
the Heckler here and there's a stubborn
there and so on and so forth I mean who
doesn't have such people in crowds if
they're if they're if they're speaking
depressed have the police contacted you
since Leicester no
so they haven't because you've been
accused of inflaming the situation and
that's the point if I did anything
criminal then the police are doing a
very poor job in uh being able to
prosecute me I've done nothing criminal
this is the point in fact I believe the
criminality has been done against me in
in the form of defamation of character
that many of these uh news outlets have
actually been a party to and so on I I
think that when they take a clip of me
talking about the hindutaba and they say
he said Hindus should so they've
literally substituted one word with
another
or they mentioned that I uh I'm
anti-jewish or something like that well
the telegram actually actually mentioned
this or that I was leading anti-jewish
protesters stuff like this I think this
is nonsense and you will never find
anything I will challenge everybody all
the media Outlets that come together and
do an extreme brainstorm take all 600
videos of mine on my channel Hammer
hijab on YouTube and to try and find
such words coming out of my mouth
is a sign of defeat when you have to lie
about the person you're reporting about
I feel like they've sabotaged their own
effort
they have dug up a video where you're in
gold as green and they said you're being
quite provocative yes and it was a much
about Palestine but then somebody they
think you was heard saying you know I'm
going to get the Jews and not Zionist
you actually use a lot of jeans no that
wasn't me that wasn't you that wasn't me
I don't think any reporter actually ever
said that was me they said somebody in a
mask said that so I don't think any um
British or even to be honestly Indian
ones actually no one said that that was
me but what'd you say about them saying
generally you know going to golders
Green with a megaphone
protesting like that is provocative the
same way it was provocative going to
Leicester well I mean the thing is we
have friends in golders green who
actually sympathize with our course who
vicariously simplifies with our cause
and these friends are Jewish friends and
we have videos of them holding hands
with us
hundreds of thousands of people have
seen these videos we're holding hands of
us saying we support Palestinian rights
I I fail to see how this kind of thing
can be anti-jewish when Jews are leading
it effectively so I think this binary
notion that Jews and zionists are the
same thing and that you cannot be Jewish
and anti-zionist or aunties I think this
is outdated now I think this is the
cliche that we need to throw that was
going to be in the trash heap of History
um to be honest with you once again it's
a tactic that is attempted by
individuals to try and stop and
anti-zionist or anti-israel kinds of
campaigns and even Jeremy corbyn people
left wing have been accused of
accidentism what do you think they're
going to do with someone like me who I'm
a semi by the way I mean I'm an Arab and
Arabic is one of the Semitic languages
because they don't allow me to uh to
manifest my pro-palestinian rights
without calling me antimatter so that's
the kind of anti-Semitism in my
understanding let me let me let me own
the phrase I will remember I mean I
don't care what they are to be honest
with you I'll be honest with you I don't
care what they have to say I mean what
they have to say is like meaningless to
the nth degree to someone like me so
quite frankly if if this is an attempt
to try and deter me from doing activism
which is pro-palestine and so on I think
it's a musically attempt in fact I
relish sometimes I enjoy even seeing
these kind of things because it shows
defeat it shows that this is desperation
that they have reached the the epitome
of desperation that they now have to
malign me through Distortion and
manipulation So when you say you enjoy
seeing it and stuff I mean the videos
are really popular they all went viral
is that part of the appeal of going down
to places like Leicester giving you
speeches because you know you would get
the clicks from it I don't know about
all that but I mean at the end of the
day I can ask channel for the same thing
I'm not I'm if you compare how much I'm
getting from these kinds of videos
compared to like but not about the money
about the influence you know you get
loads of followers through it yeah
that's something I have to struggle with
Within Myself to see what what are my
true intentions because as a Muslim
spiritually I should be effectively
doing everything for the sake of God
that is the epitome of spirituality from
the Muslim parallel the extent to which
I'm upholding that standard is something
which I don't know myself I haven't been
honest with you to what extent am I
upholding the spiritual standard that
I'm doing everything completely sincere
I have to manage my own inauthenticity
just like I think everyone else does so
the except I don't know what my
intentions are I'll add me to speak to
the psychiatrist for that or a psycho
psychotherapist
maybe the unconscious mind and the ego
and the superego are battling each other
but you know I can't I can't say much
about that apart from that but perhaps
you're right well perhaps you're right
you know
um
oh yeah so we've got Diwali coming up in
Leicester the Festival of narratri has
started if trouble does kick off again
would you go down well they're gonna
invite me or I'm going to be invited to
the temple down there
well I mean look I mean to be honest
with you
um
once again
uh I'll have to speak to the leaders of
Leicester the Muslim leaders and to uh
the police the Leicester ship release
and to see if my presence will be
conducive I might even speak to you I
might give you a call and say what do
you what do you think what do you think
what is channel four thing do you think
it'll be welcome or not welcome and
after I've made after I've spoken to
people people say not welcome well then
in that case I have to really think
deeply about it I will have to respect
the wishes of good people like you and
good people in Leicester
foreign
I'll tell you something right I'm the
kind of individual that doesn't want to
be tolerated I want to be celebrated so
if I'm going to go somewhere the people
that will get get the teeth and drinks
ready for me because I'm not going there
to the state park I'm not gonna say I'm
gonna I'm going there to take over
that's then then that'll be the click
but what I'm saying what I'm saying is
that yeah yeah I wouldn't do anything
against the wishes of the people in this
stuff on a serious note I wouldn't do
that and you wouldn't do it in the way
you did because you accept that it was
inflammatory going down speaking to a
beautiful voice it's gotten you to come
to speak to me from Channel 4 come to my
office to the micro influencers Muhammad
panjab so in many ways it's done this
purpose so I have to really think about
the pros and the cons
I mean potentially you're right I'll
give you that maybe what I did needs
refinement
and that's that is a life for human
being they look at what they've done and
they say okay this is something that I
won't do next time I mean what kind of
unaccountable person would I be if I
didn't learn anything from this
situation
um and just I was just gonna
know about
would you do it again
it depends on that I said I'll ask no
you said he'd ask people and see if it
was right now on the information you've
got right now but I'll do it right now
probably not to be honest we're probably
not yeah
probably not and unless people say
please bring the people from London and
do a protest because we need to fill up
Leicester and we need to make it uh you
know we need to do a great um you know
approaches so we know you have the
capabilities in which case I'll say
listen
you always should not come on you know
we have we have a probe of an Arabic
language
uh the the pro the proverb goes as
follows this is that
which is that the leader of a tribe is
their servant
so I would only do that which is in the
service of my people but if people in
Leicester said I mean a lot of people in
this receptionally they don't want
Outsiders coming down so if you heard
that yeah yeah I'll be deterred of
course
and in terms of um we were talking about
young Muslim men and you were talking
about you know this path to extremism
and stuff yeah it seems to me it's
somebody who grew up in Leicester we
used to call ourselves Asian you know
Asian would mean now there's a lot of
identity politics what's going on with
young Muslim men what's happening with
the Hindustan that's the question
because Islamic extremism has been
around for a very long time
I mean it's been around let's be honest
for 20 30 years in this country at least
okay and uh what the recent change has
actually not been from that side it's
been from the Hindustan side I think
that
the this radical ideology which once
again imagine one of the leaders of the
RSS the second Chief has is praising the
Holocaust and saying we need a new one
this kind of ideology which they're
teaching in madrasa's type situations
Hindu madrases in this case you know is
is finding its way in Leicester and we
have to that's what I'm saying we have
to be open just like me as a Muslim I'm
telling you I'm saying we have to be
open about our own uh kind of problems
that we have this I think is a serious
problem and that's what's causing issues
why is it now when Modi has just become
a prime minister in 2014 or whatever it
was or the BJP party which is actually
taking on this ideology why is it now
because that is the major change so you
can't make a cause causative argument
from that perspective but do you feel
there are more identity politics now
with people defining themselves by their
religion
uh what are you talking about in the
last 10 years 15 years yeah possibly I I
don't know I haven't done a sociological
study on the matter I would have to that
is an issue of sociological academics um
you know investigation
okay
um I think that was it actually if he
knows anything is it I think so I just
thought it was interesting that
you came from here I went up to
Leicester yeah and allegedly
some Hindus came from Wembley or went to
Leicester okay why doesn't what happen
unless it just happened around the
corner what do you mean uh why did why
didn't happen
if I okay I don't think so tell Donald
Trump
I don't think it would happen to London
because there's at least 1.3 million
Muslims in London
and lesser is more equally proportioned
in terms of the religious demographic so
Hindus are I don't know what the
percentage of argument Muslims but it's
more balanced whereas Birmingham
according to Census Data although the
last census of 2021 has not the data is
not published so when published in May
of 2023 I believe but um it shows that
Birmingham and Bradford in London are
the most densely populated muslimarius
so it's a matter of numbers and this is
why I called them cowards because they
do it in areas where they know that the
numbers that they're going to have more
numbers
this is a cowardly I believe it's a
cowardly approach moreover I don't think
in London this would be um you know most
Hindus and Muslims have a very close
relationship like in Wembley in these
kinds of areas they go to the same
schools they eat the same food you know
maybe not the meat but they're doing
Leicester too
yes but but I think it's once again it's
um
and Leicester this is I might be wrong
here but it's a little bit more
ghettoized
like there's more this is the Hindu area
this is the Muslim area but Wembley's
got both Muslims and Hindus there's
schools which both Muslims and Hindus go
to so I think this intermixing okay this
intermixing of different people from
different cultures we've seen this from
Pew research for example the countries
with the least amount of into mixing or
the most racist countries
so one of the best ways to eradicate
racism and racial Supremacy and these
kind of things is just pulled together
like we are in this room together
different colors different you know
Creeds and so on but we can drink
together and you can laugh we can have a
good time and this is this is how to
like on a practical level to eliminate
the hostilities
I wonder you talked about the fact
the Muslim Community
I mean you're saying
yes it does why not
if you feel that's what's going on why
not teach them how to do it rather than
going and being confrontational and
writing people up and I don't know I
don't think that I've never thought of
that as an approach now that you could
afford I'd have to study it
[Laughter]
but then we have the question okay we'll
bring the Hindu leaders to me and I'll
teach them all they want to know but
unfortunately some of these hinduisms
from these temples and so on are
complicit in bringing these Hindu for
people go over like that African name
now Randy or whatever her name is she
came abroad and she's she's an
individual with an ideological baggage
and I actually believe and I haven't got
studies to prove this because I don't
think any study has been done that the
him goods ideology as a proportion
uh of Hindus there is more support of it
than for example Islamic truism the lack
of which you see in Syria and Iraq so I
think it's a bigger problem from a
demographic perspective
um I haven't got the evidence to show
that but
um in that case it would be more
socially stigmatic for someone to come
out from a Hindu community and speak
against RSS or speak about because
you've got Modi I mean you won't be able
to go to India if you speak about these
kind of things and we go to India
probably be caught in the the airport
and they don't detain your send you back
we're talking about a an ideology that
has been an ideology that has been
accepted now by the the leaders of India
compared to a fringe ideology that's all
the leaders of the Islamic world and all
the scholars and all the centers of
powers have rejected these are these are
the complications
and you said that you know you'd think
twice about going back to lesson now the
police haven't spoke to you you've told
me to think twice about it
um you accept my vote when you're on
camera saying we have to defend
ourselves you know we're gonna
I don't remember your exact words but
you say you're saying you have a right
to defend yourself
yeah that was provocative you shouldn't
have been saying that why
because you're saying to me but it's
okay to be violent back no I mean I
think well violent back is the key Point
here I mean what pacifists if someone
slaps us I mean if someone came into
this room right now and they tried to
attack you I would get involved in the
matter but if it's a volatile situation
you've got lots of young men all hit up
on the streets you know I think it's
some vulnerable people are being hurt
like on the 22nd of May what I have
first of all there was a 30 on one
attack yeah and then after that the
mother and the father of that person
were also attacked these are vulnerable
people when I heard things like this it
really made me upset to be honest with
you because I feel like we do have a
duty of care to protect ourselves
citizenry like like I say it for me this
idea of a diffusion of responsibility
because the police what we did let the
police do with it but the police were
incapable of doing that I'm not sure if
you've seen the statistics in this
country relating to how many stabbings
happening on a yearly basis sometimes of
forty nine thousand fifty thousand these
kind of things do you really think is in
this country in Leicester I mean
Metropolitan Police music do you think
that they have a grip on this situation
well then if you write down your way it
would be vigilante as a moment it
wouldn't be because we're saying
reasonable legal reasonable Force but
why I'm against is in Psychology
referred to as a diffusion of
responsibility I'm against a woman being
sexually assaulted in the street and
everyone just filming with their phone
I'm against this individualistic and
notion egoistic notion that it's all
about me and I'm not going to get
involved I'm for a notion of Bravery
because my religion teaches me this
which you put your own self your own
life at risk to defend the lives of
others and I think if we didn't have
that mentality the freedoms that we're
all enjoying now wouldn't even exist but
if you saw you know some young Muslim
guys they must have said to you you know
we're going to go and rip a flank off a
temple okay yeah that kind of stuff that
kind of stuff is impermissible from the
Islamic perspective and I I very
categorically it's on the record told
them do not do this kind of thing the
only thing which is allowed legally is
reasonable force and I think it's
important for people to know that in our
community one thing that is plaguing not
just Leicester or London or anywhere
else but the entire UK's Community the
West is this culture of the diffusion of
responsibility just let someone else do
what they call the pity by the time you
call the police the person would be dead
that's what people need to understand
the police are not a Magic Bullet the
police are there in some situations and
sometimes they're not there sometimes
they'll do a tactical Retreat themselves
and if that wasn't the case then why
would you have a pandemic of stabbings
in this country
they they they're not holding sorry to
say but I don't think that the police
have the authority to deal with certain
things like the amount of stabbing that
we're dealing with so if it reaches that
level then the citizenry must know that
there's something called reasonable
Force which you you can use would you
condemn people pulling Flags off indexes
absolutely yes
oh that is the most condemnable thing I
can think of I mean this verse of the
Quran that you know actually negate this
kind of thing as Muslims right if we're
talking about from Islam Paradigm right
we don't believe in garnish or all of
these kind of gods and like you know
polytheistic fictitious we believe
they're mythological right we don't
believe in any of that we believe in one
God worthy of worship we believe that's
one God that's the creator of the
universe and that is responsible for the
cosmological beginnings of the human
being however the Quran explicitly says
do not mock or attack or insult the gods
of other uh you know people other gods
and so on so that they may respond in
kind in other words it's a it's a cycle
of Vengeance and a cycle of violence and
a cycle of viciousness
um which well to be honest with you full
intents and purposes I cannot
vicariously sympathize sympathize with
so it was wrong to tear down that oh yes
it was one of the most wrong things that
Muslims have done in that whole and
there was other things that they did
earlier absolutely yes very wrong and I
mean you're quite in the Quran and
saying you know but you yourself were
mocking people's belief in reincarnation
on the day I said that let me just
repeat what I said just to remind you I
said that if I believed in it I would
not want to be reincarnated as a as a
weak and pathetic and cowardly person
now who was I speaking to hindranceva
now I'm not saying the idea of
reincarnation is XYZ fill in the blanks
use mocking terms I'm saying if
conditional if I believed in it which I
don't think is geologically impossible
for an all-powerful God to reincarnate
human beings I don't believe in that
eschatologically I think it's logically
possible but you knew that wasn't the
place to have that kind of debate on the
streets that night whenever he was riled
up yeah okay I I see you're saying this
of course if you're saying this I have
to accept it yeah as a Hindu right look
I have to be accountable be respectful
and if people of the Hindu Community
like yourself or anyone else is telling
me that this was distasteful we didn't
like it that's all that you need to hear
from
you I won't do it again why as a gesture
of respect and a gesture of community
cohesion or gesture of Tolerance there's
no need for I mean this is not it's not
um it's not a mountain I want to die on
like if you felt like it was distasteful
and it was triggering and so on there's
no need for it then I won't do that
again
that sounds great